s'il vient c'est soutane de ba payant
chance est avec nous ce matin bonjour
madame cet automne un jour bonjour à
tous et à toutes
élu à la collectivité territoriale de
martinique tout comme marie des
torpilles diamant rose karina mousseau
miguel laventure yano plaisir imaginez
vous ce matin notre déception s'il vient
cette soudaine 48 heures après votre
réunion de saint joseph car nous nous
souvenons cas au mois de janvier la
batelière lors des voeux de votre
mouvement des yeux de votre regroupement
nous avaient annoncé ce week-end de
février comme étant une week-end on a ce
on annoncerait la création d'une
association politique une nouvelle
et puis finalement il n'y a pas eu ça
mais j'étais très surprise de ne pas
vous voir d'ailleurs à sa cause et vous
auriez vu qu'il ya vraiment une
dynamique très intéressant de martinique
à venir qui est un groupe de jeunes de
personnes militantes qui avait envie de
créer ce mouvement justement qui n'est
pas un mouvement politique un mouvement
pluri politique on va dire parce qu'ils
avaient envie de s'exprimer et de sortir
justement des cancans des problématiques
au on compte beaucoup dans la vie
politique aujourd'hui de ne pas
s'afficher comme tout en étant bas pays
en chancelant ne va pas on va pas se
dédire ce sont des gens qui sont proches
de nous mais qu'ils avaient envie de lui
d'élargir la base et d'élargir la
discussion au prélat que de 2 des gens
de la martinique donc c'est vraiment
dans cette dynamique qu'ils se
positionnent et je les félicite parce
que c'est quelque chose qui me semble
intéressant quand on parle de démocratie
participative
on résume la situation les élus de ba
payant chance qu'ils sont pas à la ctm
dans la majorité ne m'ont pas donc créé
un nouveau mouvement il ya juste une
association à côté qui va faire
exactement alors qui va justement aller
à la rencontre des gens je pense que
vous avez reçu les sms qu'on a envoyé on
a envoyé un sms qu'ils aiment à
martinique je la vois comment et
pourquoi est on répond si on a eu de
nombreuses personnes qui sont
intervenues qui sont alors de tous les
horizons et qui ont répondu en disant
voilà comment on voit la martinique plus
juge la fameuse démocratie participative
hamelin malheureusement c'est un peu de
mal sur le sujet d ensemble c'est trop
bon c'est un peu normal parce qu'en fait
on se rend bien compte et monsieur parti
en a un peu parlé dans son éditorial
il faut vraiment que les gens
s'expriment et qu'ils disent ce qu'ils
veulent parce qu'aujourd'hui un peuple
ne peut plus ne peut plus subir
un peuple doit décider et donc quand on
décide c'est quand on s'exprime et quand
on reste dans son coin a maugréé en
disant non non non non ça ne marche pas
cette prime on peut être relayée par des
gens comme moi ils sont très à l'écouté
par des gens comme karine qui sont très
à l'écouté et on peut relier ni les
choses c'est ce qui a fait d'ailleurs
que même si je suis j'aurais aimé être
invite à une autre émission sur la money
l'harmonisation des tarifs des
collégiens et collégiennes de la rentrée
septembre 2019 oui c'est totalement il
n'y a pas deux il n'y a pas de barrière
à b en chant c'est un parti c'est une
c'est une partie c'est un mouvement ces
regroupements de gens qui prennent
ensemble et qu'ils ont envie de faire
avancer les choses
ouais donc c'est ce qu'on fait depuis
qu'on est élu dans cette majorité ont
fait avancer les choses malgré les
freins que nous rencontrons depuis le
début on fait avancer les choses
c'est un regroupement s'est déjà moment
au moment où arrive certaines élections
il ne s'est pas bientôt on va en parler
il y aura les européennes il aura les
municipales il n'y a pas nécessité a pas
obligation de créer un véritable parti
politique puisque chacun des membres de
ba payant chance vallat quoi justement
vous l'avait bien dit on le dit tout le
temps là les gens commencent à se méfier
des partis politiques on a de nouveau
parti qui arrive qui arrive comme ça
avec des noms qui ressemble fortement à
des choses qui existent déjà et en fait
non ça c'est le plus haut d'aujourd'hui
c'est un peu normal mais bon c'est mc
bref c'est un peu facile facile de le
dire mais c'est pas un parti politique
qui va apporter une réponse aux gens
c'est la discussion
c'est le fait de les associer le plus au
projet commun qu'on pourrait avoir en
martinique
c'est ce qu'il faut qu'on sorte que
chaque personne se dit bon bah si on a
une crème à faire on va peut-être
réfléchir parce que ben ça va impacter
la vie de deux plaintes femmes qui n'ont
pas de voiture et keane qui sont
malheureusement aujourd'hui obligés de
rester chez elle pas ce matin ça roule
un peu oui c'est un projet qui va nous
permet de se dire ah non se mettre
ensemble et pas de se tirer chaque fois
les uns sur les autres c'est assez
fatigant
cicas ait soutane c'est très tendance
c'est très tendance de
de voir une association qui sort comme
ça de terre à côté d'un regroupement
politique par exemple pays à une
association pour ses finances notre
parti revendique même procédé c'est une
façon pour vous de
de dissocier les choses sa virginité
non non pas du tout c'est vraiment le
fait que les gens qui sont donc ils sont
sympathisants et sympathisantes de
papier en chance avait envie de se
mettre ensemble pour répondre à des
problématiques que tout le monde se pose
parce que par exemple j'imagine
quelqu'un qui est au mime et qui a envie
quand même de parler avec moi de la
sécurité des établissements scolaires
bon il va peut-être venir si puisqu'il
se conjuguer ouverte mais n'est pas
forcément il n'a pas forcément envie de
devenir dans la réunion bas péan chance
on va pas le voilà bien sûr se dégage
alors là c'est du verglas du camouflage
je vous pose des questions des gens qui
me connaissent et qui me connaissent
savent qu'on n'est pas dans cette
dynamique à quiconque pour ba payant
chance ce sera quoi votre actualité de
faire des réunions mensuelles
régulièrement meilhan on avait déjà
commencé à faire campagne avait déjà
initié vous suit on va continuer sur ce
rythme la fois que je pense qu'en plus
il est important de que les gens se
rendent compte qu est-ce qu on est
beaucoup et intimiste rose en martinique
on a l'impression que rien ne va que
rien ne marche et quand on vient à nos
réunions on se rend compte que l'action
que nous menons nous si cela en tout cas
on parle de nous et parce que chaque
personne parle un peu de ses affaires et
si ça fait un trou tant mieux se rend
compte quelque chose avance et chaque
fois les gens qui viennent à nos
réunions ça que pas depuis deux mois se
paie depuis quelques mois qu'on a
commencé on va continuer au mois d'avril
mai juin et tous les mois on se rend
compte que vraiment les gens se dit ah
ben oui une empathie wall street à
l'avancé bien ça pour tout le bon et on
sort un peu de ce bug là justement où on
veut nous emmener où rien ne va
m'expliquer cette sinistrose
vous savez moi je trouve qu'il ya des
gens qui à cause de l'action des
politiques c'est un peu lié parce qu'on
a vraiment à mon avis comportements des
uns et des autres des gens qui
n'arrivent pas à communiquer ensemble on
a des gens qui sont peut-être chagrin et
qui n'arrivent pas à communiquer
ensemble et ce qui fait qu'on a des gens
qui vont se retrouver dans dix dans des
situations conflictuelles
là-haut moi par exemple je me retrouve
pas du tout je n'arrive pas à me à me
retrouver dans ce genre de situation où
on va parler ensemble du bien-être de la
population et on va avoir des gens qui
vont s'ériger en défenseurs moi je suis
un peu perdu dans ses confrontations
s'est passé hier par exemple aux membres
de sos ça ça m'a fait rire ça fait peur
oui votre journal fameux syriaque sommet
caisse quelqu'un que j'apprécie beaucoup
et là et la présentation de ceux de se
faire c'est marie ou d'ailleurs je
n'étais pas invitée j'étais déçu
j'aurais pu serait bienvenu et est en
fête et chansons ses chances ont alterné
de monsieur ni l'or et de monsieur
marie-jeanne m'ont beaucoup fait rire
mais je reconnais que c'était c'est
alfred marie jeanne et jean philippe
miller qui était présent hier à la fête
des courses et les choses évoluent pauli
en politique c'est ça c'est moi ce que
j'aimerais vraiment entendre c'est que
on travaille ensemble pour le mieux-être
de la population et qu'on ait des axes
forts moi je dis parle par exemple pour
ma partie de l'éducation
j'aimerais que quand je finisse le
mandat qu'on me dise la we said soutane
a quand même travaillé elle a travaillé
pour la mobilité dans la caraïbe la mode
travailler pour les établissements sait
qu en martinique elle a travaillé pour
le plan natation parce qu'on est une île
et que nos enfants ne soient pas
suffisamment nager et qu'on me
m'identifie n'ont pas parlé qu'en tant
que j'aurai à porter ou les petites
phrases assassines
mais plutôt par l'action ge aurait mené
auprès ce qu'il faut faire pour sortir
de ces petites phrases assassines de ses
concurrents il faut essayer de trouver
de l'apaisement
il faut aussi trouver l'apaisement et de
ne pas toujours prendre tous pour toi il
faut faire revenir des détachements il
faut faire venir des coachs eux
moi je pense qu'il faut vraiment prendre
du fer du d'état détachement et essayer
de sortir de ces conflits permanents et
ça c'est une question de personne de de
ce positionnement par rapport à vous
mais sa jolie pour tout le monde dans la
rue aussi quand on est au volant et
qu'on commence à insulter la personne
parce qu'elle roule pas assez vite ses
limites à 70 il faut aussi de sueur
choix de travailler pour faire en sorte
que l'on ait une matt martin qu'apaiser
c'est ce qu'on aimerait tous et tout je
pense oui
avec la période des élections ça va pas
s'arranger ben peut-être choisir aussi
des gens qui sont qui sont simples dans
leur antre c'est quelque chose que je
demande à la population des gens qui me
font de nous faire son choix
moi je sais ce que je pense moi j'ai
envie vraiment que qu'en 2021 je le dis
très sincèrement qu'on puisse avoir une
équipe qui a envie de faire avancer les
choses semblent sans problème quel est
votre podium des personnalités politique
martiniquaise à faire le plus de kankan
non je ne vais pas aller sur ce sujet là
parce que j'avais envie ni mail à la
polémique et en sortant de cette
émission dure et mon téléphone qui va
sonner en exemple si bien je n'aurais
pas dû non j en suis je n'aime pas ça
chaque personne se regardent être son
miroir chaque personne si ce qu'il fait
personne ressent le cancan mais moi je
pense que ce n'est pas une bonne chose
pour nous en martinique
on va rentrer dans un cycle d'élections
dans quelques jours à basse-pointe
heures bah payant chance a pris position
oui également paysanne avait dit en
janvier justement qui est patrick marier
l'eau que nous défendons c'est un homme
qui a montré son attachement aux gens
justement par son passage
cette association s'est dit qui fait un
travail remarquable de la d'insertion et
donc ils partagent des valeurs qui nous
sont proches les européennes
alors non franchement je vous dis on n'a
pas tellement parler on n'a pas trop
trop pris ce sujet on le prendra
certainement mais on ne s'est pas
positionné sur les locaux dès votre
positionnement les uns les autres de
bons payeurs choses concernant les
municipales chacun fera en fonction de
sa chance qu'on a on a quand même
marinette qui sait déjà qui est déjà en
campagne sont également et de la censure
c'est clair mais tous les efforts seront
mis sur le septième en 2021 on aimerait
vraiment effectivement qu'on puisse
développer le projet que nous avions
déjà en 2015 et que nous avions proposé
la population et quand on regarde si
vous revenez comme je sais que vous
aimez revenir sur les dossiers si vous
revenez sur nos programmes d'action en
2015 ce que nous avions proposé la
population vous allez voir que la
majeure partie des points que nous
avions soulignées ont été réalisés le
viaduc de fond l'ail et c'est quelque
chose qui va être opérationnel le
programme action anglais plus pour que
nos enfants soient trilingue en
martinique on a des projets que nous
avons porté qui sont effectifs
aujourd'hui de tout eau avant de se
séparer
s'ils essayent soutane bas payant chance
va devenir un vrai parti politique un
vrai mouvement une vraie association
en tout cas on va travailler pour que ça
soit quelque chose effectivement qui ait
du sens et qui puisse fédérer
merci beaucoup d'avoir été sur la table
m je vous attends pour un prochain
rendez vous sur l'harmonisation des
tarifs des des rom là parce que j'ai pas
été entendu à martin première et ça m'a
beaucoup manqué aux lolo je vous promets
qu'on y reviendra bonne journée
[Musique]